THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
MOMENTS AGO TRUMP ADDRESSING THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION CRISIS
FACING OUR COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT TAKING AIM AT
DEMOCRATS AND BLAMING THEM FOR
THE LAWS THAT ENABLED THE
PROBLEM.
>> President Trump: WE WILL
NOT ALLOW OUR GENEROSITY TO BE
ABUSED BY THOSE WHO WOULD BREAK
OUR LAWS, DEFY OUR RULES, VIA --
VIOLATE OUR BORDERS, BREAK INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
THE LAWS ARE SO BAD.
THEY ARE NOT ARCHAIC.
THEY ARE INCOMPETENT.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY ARE OLD.
THEY ARE JUST BAD.
AND WE CAN'T GET ANY DEMOCRAT
VOTES TO CHANGE THEM.
IT'S ONLY THE REPUBLICANS THAT
ARE -- THEY WANT TO CHANGE THEM.
>> Jesse: THE HOT-BUTTON ISSUE
HAS BEEN THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
HEADED TOWARDS THE
UNITED STATES.
TRUMP ONCE AGAIN VOWING TO STOP
IT.
>> President Trump: AT THIS
VERY MOMENT, LARGE, WELL
ORGANIZED MIGRANTS OF --
CARAVANS OF MIGRANTS ARE HEADED
TO OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT AN INVASION.
IT'S LIKE AN INVASION.
THESE ARE TOUGH PEOPLE COME IN
MANY CASES.
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,T
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,E
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,N
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,M
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,Y
YOUNG     YOUNG MEN, STRONGMEN,E
WE DON'T WANT IN OUR COUNTRY.
THESE CARAVANS WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY SHOULD TURN BACK NOW.
THEY ARE WASTING THEIR TIME.
THEY SHOULD APPLY TO COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
WE WANT THEM TO COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT HE WILL CRACKDOWN ON
MERITLESS CLAIMS FOR ASYLUM.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
FINALIZING A PLAN TO END THE
RAMPANT ABUSE OF OUR ASYLUM
SYSTEM.
THE ILLEGAL ALIENS WERE NO
LONGER GET A FREE PASS INTO OUR
COUNTRY BY LODGING MERITLESS
CLAIMS IN SEEKING ASYLUM.
INSTEAD, MIGRANTS SEEKING ASYLUM
WILL HAVE TO PRESENT THEMSELVES
LAWFULLY AT A PORT OF ENTRY.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
LAWFULLY PRESENT THEMSELVES AT A
PORT OF ENTRY.
>> Jesse: JUAN, TWO ISSUES.
BECAUSE OF THE LAWS IN THIS
COUNTRY, THEY TREAT PEOPLE FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA DIFFERENT THAN
THEY TREAT PEOPLE FROM CANADA OR
MEXICO.
IF YOU COME WITH A CHILD AND
YOU'RE FROM A CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRY NEW CROSS THE BORDER AND
IF YOU SAY YOU ARE FEELING
VIOLENCE, THEY WILL IMMEDIATELY
ACCEPT YOU INTO THIS COUNTRY AND
RELEASE YOU INTO THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF THE LAWS.
DO YOU THINK THE SYSTEM IS BEING
GAMED BY PEOPLE?
THERE IS LAWYERS DOWN THERE
TELLING THEM WHAT TO SAY RIGHT
BEFORE THE CROSS.
WOULD YOU MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION PROBLEM
AT ALL?
>> Juan: YEAH, WELL, IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE WITH
REGARD TO THE ASYLUM RULES, IT'S
UP TO US AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND WE CAN DO THAT AT ANY TIME.
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRATS CAN
HELP WITH THAT AT ANY TIME.
>> Juan: YES, IT'S THE
REPUBLICANS WERE FAILED TO DO IT
IN THE TWO YEARS THEY'VE BEEN
WITH TRUMP.
THERE HAVE BEEN PACKAGES FOR
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
THAT HAVE BEEN DEFEATED BY
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
I FIND IT, IS THIS BIZARRE?
IS IT HALLOWEEN STILL?
REPUBLICANS CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY OR TAXES APPARENTLY, SO
THEY START A CULTURE WAR AND
DEMONIZE THESE POOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRAGGLERS, THOUSANDS OF
MILES AWAY FROM THE BORDER AND
DON'T HAVE ANY --
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE OUR
MILITARY.
TRUMP IS CREATING A PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY TO SPUR REPUBLICAN
TURNOUT.
IT'S SO TRANSPARENT.
I'VE GOT TO THINK, ARE PEOPLE
THAT STUPID THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO FALL FOR THIS TIME AFTER TIME
AFTER TIME?
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT WAS THE ONE WHO
STARTED THE CARAVAN.
THERE WAS A CARAVAN CRISIS
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
HE CHOSE TO HANDLE IT ONE WAY.
THE PRESIDENT NOW HIS HAND ON
THE DIFFERENTLY.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING THAT
THERE IS NO CRISIS NOW.
>> Jesse: I BELIEVE THERE IS.
>> Morgan: THE CARAVAN IS
MISSING THE FOREST FOR THE
TREES.
IT'S SYMBOLIC OF THE IMMIGRATION
FIGHT AND THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE MANY AMERICANS, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT POLLING, WHY IS THE
PRESIDENT BRINGING THIS UP?
YOU LOOK AT REPUBLICAN VOTERS,
THIS IS THE TOP OF THEIR LIST,
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE.
I THINK PEOPLE IN GENERAL ARE
FRUSTRATED THAT THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE MADE NO PROGRESS ON THIS.
THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON THE
WALL.
HE'S GONE SOME MONEY FOR THE
WALL BUT HE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
GET EVERYTHING HE WANTS.
FOR ME, THEY CARAVAN IS A LARGER
REPRESENTATION OF FRUSTRATION
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT FOR NOT
SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY HE'S BRINGING IT OUT.
IT'S A POLITICAL WINNER FOR HIM.
>> Jesse: AND THE TIMING A
WEEK BEFORE, AND A BIG
WHITE HOUSE BEACH AND TOOK A FEW
QUESTIONS.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
START THE CARAVAN.
IT'S NOT HIS PROBLEM, NOT HIS
FAULT CARAVAN STARTED A MONTH
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
HE DIDN'T START IT.
THE VISUALS, THAT WAS NOT OF HIS
CREATION.
HE DIDN'T MAKE IT UP OUT OF
WHOLE CLOTH.
IT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
THERE IS A PICTURE TODAY OF THE
4-YEAR-OLD GIRL WHO WAS SO
EXHAUSTED SHE REFUSED TO GO ANY
FURTHER IN THE IT'S A
HUMANITARIAN PROBLEM.
NOT HIS FAULT.
HE'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO DO SOMETHING WITH IT.
HE TOLD THEM GO BACK.
I THINK HE COULD GO A STEP
FURTHER AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN NOW BUT HE CHOSE
THE ROOSEVELT ROOM FOR A REASON.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
BEHIND HIM.
HE WASN'T AT A CAMPAIGN RALLY.
HE DID IT IN THE ROOSEVELT ROOM
WHERE YOU DECIDE POLICY.
HE IS SAYING THIS IS A POLICY WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
I THINK THE SPEECH COULD'VE BEEN
A LITTLE SHORTER MAYBE BUT THIS
IS WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
I ALSO FEEL LIKE IT'S CLEAR WE
NEED AN ORDERLY PROCESS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO SEPARATE
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE REALLY IN NEED?
MY CONCERN ABOUT PUSHING
ASYLUM-SEEKERS,
HONEST-TO-GOODNESS PEOPLE WITH
INTEGRITY THAT HAVE THE NEED FOR
ASYLUM, TO PUSH THEM TO A PORT
OF ENTRY, THEY MIGHT BE SO
DESPERATE THAT THEY CAN'T GET
THERE.
I THINK YOU CAN TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEBODY WHO
WANTS TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE AND
THE CHANCE TO LIVE IN AMERICA
VERSUS SOMEBODY WHO'S REALLY
DESPERATELY FLEEING VIOLENCE
FROM THEIR GOVERNMENT.
>> Jesse: COULD YOU MIGRATE TO
A PORT OF ENTRY?
>> Dana: MIGHT BE ABLE TO.
I THINK A LOT OF THIS STUFF IS
HANDLED OF THE EMBASSY LEVEL AND
OTHER PLACES OVERSEAS.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS I
FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT SOLVES THE
PROBLEM AT ITS SOURCE.
CAPITALISM IS THE ANSWER.
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT COULD
DO SOMETHING, WHATEVER HAPPENS
IN THE MIDTERMS, WHO CARES.
HE'S PRESIDENT FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS AND HE'S RUNNING FOR
REELECTION.
WHAT COULD HE DO THAT WOULD BE
BIG AND DIFFERENT?
WHAT ABOUT A MARSHALL PLAN TYPE
THING FOR A VERY NEGLECTED PART
OF THE WORLD, LATIN AMERICA,
CENTRAL AMERICA, SOUTH AMERICA.
WHEN I DO SOMETHING BIG AND BOLD
TO REINTRODUCE CAPITALISM,
SOMETHING GENERATIONAL THAT
WOULD HAVE A LASTING IMPACT AND
WILL GO    GO ALONG MODULES BORE
WILL GO    GO ALONG MODULES BORR
SECURITY BUT TRY TO BRING EVIL
TOGETHER IN STABLE WANT TO TAKE
CARE OF THE REGION AND PROTECT
OUR BORDERS, LET'S DO SOMETHING
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
>> Morgan: MARK GREEN IS
TRYING TO REFORM USAID THAT
WE'VE BEEN GIVING TO CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES.
IT'S NOT JUST THE U.S. MEXICAN
BORDER.
WE ARE SEEING THE SAME THING
HAPPENED IN THE FAILED STATE OF
VENEZUELA.
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS A DAY,
PEOPLE GOING TO THE COLOMBIAN
BORDER.
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THIS SIMILARLY
TO THE WAY WE LOOKED AT FAILED
STATES IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND SO
MANY YEARS.
I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU AND I
THINK MARK GREEN OF USAID HAS A
GREAT PLAN.
>> Greg: I THINK A LOT OF
THESE PROBLEMS ARE DUE TO HOW
THE MEDIA POSITION OF THE
ISSUES.
JUAN BRINGS UP THE FACT THAT NO
ONE BRINGS UP THE ECONOMY.
IT'S BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS
GREAT RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE 3.5% TO 4%
GROWTH.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT PLANES THAT LAND SAFELY.
THEY CAN ONLY REPORT ON PLANES
THAT CRASHED.
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THE ECONOMY
MYSTERIOUSLY IS NO NEWS ON THE
OTHER NETWORKS.
WE TRIED TO TALK ABOUT IT HERE
BUT IT'S OFTEN IGNORED BECAUSE
IT IS SUCH GOOD NEWS.
NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
DONALD TRUMP HAD TO SET THE
ISSUE UP AT THE BEGINNING AS A
STRAIN ON THE SYSTEM.
THE REASON IS, THE MEDIA
BELIEVES YOU CAN ONLY HOLD TWO
POSITIONS.
YOU CAN EITHER SAY WE ARE A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS OR HITS A
NATION UNDER SIEGE.
THE FACT IS WHAT HUMAN BEINGS
HOLD UP PORTFOLIO OF POSITIONS
REGARDING EVERYTHING, LIKE
IMMIGRATION, YOU CAN HOLD A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT POSITIONS ON
CRIME.
I CAN BE FOR THE DEATH PENALTY
BUT THINK DRUGS SHOULD BE
LEGALIZED.
YOU CAN HAVE A PORTFOLIO OF
INTERESTS ABOUT CLIMATE.
YOU CAN BELIEVE THERE IS CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT THAT THE POLICIES ARE
WRONG.
BUT THE ACTIVIST MEDIA BANDS
NUANCE SO IF YOU HAVE A -- IF
YOU FEEL FOR STRONG IMMIGRATION
AND YOU WANT PEOPLE TO COME HERE
BUT YOU WANT TO TIGHTEN THE
LOOPHOLES, IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
THE MEDIA.
IT DOESN'T COMPUTE.
THEY NEED TO HAVE YOU IN YOUR
OWN BOX, AND IT'S SO INFURIATING
BECAUSE I AM FOR STRONG
IMMIGRATION PERK I WANT PEOPLE
TO COME HERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WANTS
PEOPLE TO COME HERE, BUT IN HIS
BRAIN, HE KNOWS, LIKE EVERYBODY
WHO'S IMMERSED IN THIS KIND OF
LAW & ORDER CRITERIA THAT YOU
KEEP IN YOUR BRAIN THAT THERE
HAS TO BE A SYSTEM, THAT SYSTEM
ENABLES YOU TO HAVE A PORTFOLIO
OF BELIEFS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE MEDIA CANNOT
HANDLE THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE
STUPID.
>> Juan: I WANT TO QUICKLY SAY
IT'S NOT JUST THE MEDIA.
YOU LOOK AT THE ADS, THERE'S A
TON OF ADS RIGHT NOW GOING INTO
THE WEEKEND, AND THE ADS RUN BY
THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, GREG, BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GAINING TRACTION WITH
THE VOTERS.
>> Greg: THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Juan: AND I WOULD SAY BUT
LOOK AT THE AD THAT IS BEING
RUN, THE PRESIDENT RETWEETED IT,
SOME MEXICAN GUY WHO SHOT I
THINK A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
SAYING I'M COMING BACK.
I'M GOING TO KILL MORE.
MY GOSH.
THIS IS WILLIE HORTON ALL OVER
AGAIN?
WE KNOW FROM THE NUMBERS THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY
HAVE A LOWER RATE OF VIOLENT
CRIME THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE NATIVE
BORN.
>> Greg: WASN'T WRONG TO POINT
OUT THAT WILLIE HORTON WAS A
FURLOUGHED KILLER?
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF WILLIE
HORTON?
>> Juan: I AM ON THE SIDE OF
NOT PLAYING TO RACIAL
ANTAGONISM.
>> Greg: IT IS ABOUT CRIME AND
SAFETY, NOT RACE.
YOU ARE SEEING RACE.